Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Design.
Ne sentiamo tanto parlare:
è un termine che è entrato
nel linguaggio comune,
tutti lo utilizzano;
non sempre si ha l'impressione
che sia chiaro a tutti
di cosa stiamo parlando.
Un famoso progettista
ha usato la metafora
di una "parola valigia".
In realtà ce ne sono molte,
nella nostra società, di "parole valigia":
innovazione, sostenibilità.
Il tema, per quanto riguarda il design,
è che c'è scritto fuori design,
e dentro ognuno ci mette
un po' quello che vuole.
Proviamo a capirci di più.
Proviamo a partire da un accordo
che identifichi un ambito
di intervento, un'area.
Diciamo che il design si occupa
del progetto delle cose
della nostra vita quotidiana.
A volte sono fisiche,
altre volte sono immateriali;
a volte sono semplicemente dei servizi.
Poi entreremo sul concetto
di progettazione,
e capiremo come si sviluppa
il percorso che porta a un progetto.
La ulteriore problematica,
attorno alla parola design,
è che non ce n'è uno solo.
Ci sono tantissime possibilità
di espressione del design.
Io sono entrato su questo palco
con un carrello di un supermercato,
sul quale ci sono diversi oggetti
che voglio passare velocemente
in rassegna con voi
per dire che non stiamo parlando
di una cosa sola;
e questo rende a volte difficile
una definizione univoca;
ma possiamo parlare di tante cose,
da quando ci svegliamo al mattino
e facciamo un caffè -
classica caffettiera italiana,
esito di un lavoro
di pensiero progettuale,
nonché di messa in produzione
da parte di un industriale,
per cui un designer imprenditore;
se non vogliamo il caffè,
possiamo andare su una teiera:
questa è la riprogettazione
del concetto di teiera classica,
con una piccola invenzione
che è legata al fatto
che quando l'acqua bolle
c'è un fischietto,
un fischietto che vorrebbe richiamare
il suono delle navi nei porti.
Dopodiché andiamo a casa, o al bar,
e abbiamo le nostre tazzine.
Alcune si sono riuscite ad affermare
per via di una loro forte riconoscibilità,
magari legata a un segno
particolare, a una decorazione:
ma dopodiché, nella nostra casa
ce ne sono ancora un'infinità differenti
di tipologie di oggetti,
e ognuno di questi che io vi sto mostrando
ha un iter differente,
perché se sto lavorando alla ceramica
la faccio in un modo,
se faccio l'acciaio
ha ancora altre caratteristiche,
se faccio il vetro stampato,
come in questo caso -
qui siamo in terra veneta,
per cui molti riconosceranno una forma
che ha ispirato un'altra forma,
fatto a Murano, con il vetro soffiato;
ma questo è forse l'archetipo
che nasce da un'altra parte,
con un'altra tecnologia,
che è ancora diversa dalla tecnologia
che mi permette di stampare
un vaso in plastica
cercando una doppia funzionalità
in un senso o nell'altro.
Qui vedete una lampada
che forse conoscete,
che è, probabilmente,
l'oggetto più venduto del design italiano
contemporaneo nel mondo;
ma quando pensiamo al design,
e al lavoro di progettazione,
non dobbiamo pensare solo
agli oggetti fisici che conosciamo,
ai prodotti;
il lavoro funziona
anche per la comunicazione.
Io vi sto mostrando un quotidiano italiano
che ha una ricerca, per quanto
riguarda il progetto visivo,
molto ricercata.
Vi posso mostrare un libro -
noi tutti li abbiamo, ed è importante
che continueremo ad averli.
Che è l'esito di un progetto grafico
dello stesso giovane designer
che ha preparato la ricerca
sulle font che compaiono in queste slide.
Plurale, quindi: non uno, ma tanti.
E per questo fa fatica
ad avere un'unica definizione.
Sono entrato con un carrello
perché è importante anche collocare
il senso del lavoro dei progettisti.
Bruno Munari,
forse molti di voi sanno chi è
e l'hanno conosciuto
nei suoi libri e nei suoi lavori,
un artista e designer italiano
molto capace alla divulgazione,
al lavoro anche con i bambini,
diceva che in realtà la destinazione,
il destino ultimo del lavoro dei designer
non è tanto il museo;
e a volte, per il design,
l'equivoco rispetto all'opera d'arte
c'è stato, talvolta permane,
ma non credo che sia appropriato.
Il destino dei designer
è quello di entrare nei supermercati,
entrare nella vita delle persone comuni.
Una delle grandi differenze,
rispetto ad altri ambiti
espressivi, comunicativi
o di elaborazione
di artefatti in senso lato
a partire da un'opera d'arte
o ad altre dimensioni del progetto,
è il fatto che nasce da un compito.
Vale a dire,
il design non è un atto creativo
indipendente da una serie di condizioni,
ma le condizioni all'interno
di cui viene collocato determinano,
queste condizioni determinano
la sua direzione, le sue scelte,
dove vuole arrivare
e a che cosa vuole rispondere,
a quali bisogni, quali desideri nuovi,
speranze vuole suscitare;
quali risposte vuole dare
alle condizioni del mondo.
È chiaro che progettare vuol dire
considerare tanti passaggi:
partire da un'idea,
un'idea che si determina
o per un'ispirazione
oppure in considerazione
a condizioni, perché no, del mercato,
alle necessità di vita delle persone.
Questo poi diventa -
attraverso un confronto
con altre componenti
delle realtà produttive,
o anche della dimensione
sociale, o istituzionale,
che determina dei processi
di intervento progettuale
che chiamiamo design -
diventa poi una situazione
che viene prodotta, viene distribuita,
deve entrare in canali
che possano arrivare alle persone.
A volte la distribuzione è affiancata
da una dimensione di comunicazione,
molto importante;
e va guardato, poi,
come gli artefatti entrano
nella dimensione del consumo.
E da ultimo,
ed è una dimensione molto importante
nella condizione contemporanea,
dove appunto di sostenibilità
si parla molto spesso,
è di grandissima rilevanza immaginare
che i prodotti che pensiamo
debbano entrare nel mondo
possono essere poi anche gestiti
nella loro uscita dal mondo,
possano essere progettati
perché possano essere in parte
disassemblati, riutilizzati,
o avere nuovi cicli di vita.
Per fare tutto questo, evidentemente,
non basta una persona:
il design è un lavoro di gruppo,
è un lavoro di gruppo
che coinvolge tante competenze,
che vanno dall'imprenditore
che sceglie di mettere
in produzione un tuo prodotto,
e con quale devi dialogare,
sia un quotidiano,
un libro, o una lampada;
ma qualcuno deve darti dei vincoli
che determinano il tuo percorso.
Dopodiché, i designer parlano
con gli ingegneri,
parlano con gli esperti di materiali,
con gli esperti di marketing:
e tutto questo dialogo
è quello che determina
quello che noi definiamo come il design,
cioè un processo complessivo condiviso.
"È un processo" vuol dire
che non è un atto creativo, dal nulla:
c'è un lungo percorso
che coinvolge molti attori -
per questo va condiviso -
ed è complessivo:
si occupa dell'idea
fino alla gestione del ciclo di vita,
possibilmente in un processo,
in una complessiva concezione
attenta ad alcuni valori.
In questi tempi, ad esempio, l'ambiente;
ma lo stesso utilizzo
che ne fanno le persone.
Il ruolo del design,
all'interno di questo lavoro,
è quello di fare sintesi,
è di condividere il processo
dal punto di partenza fino all'esito.
In questo carrello,
io ho collocato prodotti
di diversa qualità, di diversa notorietà,
di diverso successo:
ma tutti unificati dall'idea
di un buon progetto,
di cui il lavoro del designer,
alla fine, determina una sintesi.
Per questo possiamo parlare
del designer, e dei designer,
come portatori di una competenza precisa,
di una disciplina precisa.
C'è una difficoltà a definire
la disciplina del design,
e anche ad affermare
la figura del designer:
la parola disciplina indica
che esiste un processo razionale,
esiste una metodologia,
esistono delle competenze
che non sono di tutti,
altrimenti si fa
del lavoro dilettantesco -
e talvolta capita,
che nell'ambito del design
ci siano dei dilettanti;
ma non è il caso di molte cose
che vi ho mostrato, e di molto agire.
Tutti dobbiamo andare
in un'altra direzione.
Diciamo che c'è una disciplina
che si forma lungo modalità,
e strumentazioni,
che sono di tipo razionale, condivisibile.
Ma poi, il design ha qualcosa di più,
nel senso che arriva un momento
in cui serve uno scarto,
che è quello dell'ispirazione,
che è quello del talento.
Per cui il design non è
un esito finale, di sintesi,
a cui si può arrivare
attraverso metodologie quantitative,
razionalmente e interamente determinabili:
a un certo punto, l'atto finale di sintesi
deve attingere a mondi di ispirazione,
a mondi di poesia, di bellezza,
di talento anche personale.
È importante capirlo,
perché è quello che determina la qualità,
che poi diventa la qualità
della nostra vita quotidiana.
Noi oggi viviamo una condizione in cui -
come esseri umani, come progettisti,
ma chiunque agisce nel mondo
si trova di fronte a grandi sfide.
Possiamo probabilmente dire
che è una transizione tra mondi,
che è quella che stiamo vedendo,
più o meno accelerata
da alcune grandi crisi,
dove si sta determinando, oggettivamente,
un nuovo sistema di valori:
stiamo probabilmente superando
una dimensione della nostra
vita quotidiana
fortemente segnata
per quanto riguarda il progetto,
la produzione, il consumo,
da una dimensione di consumo infinito,
che vuol dire spreco infinito di risorse
e consumo infinito di energia.
Tutto questo, forse, non è più quello
che c'è bisogno nel mondo,
come esseri umani e come progettisti.
Come progettisti, ci sentiamo di prendere
la responsabilità di portare nel mondo,
sostenuti dalle persone
che stanno cambiando il loro modo
di pensare e di agire nel mondo,
dei valori diversi.
La pluricitata, in questa
mia comunicazione, sostenibilità
fino all'usabilità
dei prodotti, dei servizi
per tutte le persone,
dai bambini alle persone anziane.
Ancora, il confronto
con i sistemi tecnologici
che sappiamo segneranno il nostro futuro
deve riuscire ad arrivare a un livello
per cui diventano strumenti e non fini.
Ed è una sfida importante.
Per definire che cosa,
oggi, fanno i designer,
forse per definire
che cosa fa ognuno di noi
come essere umano nel mondo,
può esserci d'aiuto questa etichetta
che dice che il designer è,
in qualche modo, diventato un giardiniere.
E ancora, a maggior ragione,
questa citazione
da un economista che dice che, alla fine,
ognuno di noi esseri umani,
a maggior ragione chi produce
cose nel mondo -
idee, cose fisiche, o azioni -
si è trovato in una
condizione di passaggio:
non doveva più solo fare all'infinito,
ma doveva porsi nella condizione
di salvaguardare, operare
in modo da salvaguardare
le condizioni dell'esistente.
Il concetto di cura
è diventato di grande rilevanza;
ma se vogliamo curarci davvero
dell'ambiente, delle persone,
e il design è uno degli strumenti,
probabilmente di design dobbiamo parlare
ai bambini, fin dalle scuole,
finché cominciano a formarsi, a studiare.
E a questo punto, la nostra cura
di esseri umani e di progettisti
diventerà la cura
delle persone e del mondo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)